I watched the I watched that Poirier
Alvarez fight this weekend and if you're
not familiar with these two but these
two bad boys they are UFC prize fighters
and these I mean these are the kind of
dudes I'll tell you this I wouldn't take
their daughter on a date you know I'm
saying these are some real bad boys you
know and they're good guys but they see
you know they're Romans they're you know
they're guys they're finishing one of
these dudes will probably might fight a
tiger in a few years or someone the
internet for a big purse you know the
other kind of these these are some you
know these are some real hitters and
both of them are lightweights but I
wouldn't tell them that but they're
ranked number four and three and on the
charts you know in that lightweight UFC
chart so their chart neighbors bro their
you know their chart neighbors so you
know that this fight was gonna be a real
you know a real fiasco you know what I'm
saying this thing I mean and people were
fired up because they fought it before
they already fought one time and they
were coming back for more
so here's the thing dude I remember most
of the people I ever fought beat my ass
bruh and so I'm cool you know I'm saying
if people were like you want to go back
from a war I'll be like I'm good but
these gentlemen these bad battleships
want her to straight-up you know they
wanted to swim in each other's ocean
again and so this was a Poirier alvarez
part two and you got Eddie Alvarez man
and this guy Eddie Alvarez
I mean it's him I keep him fighting his
whole life I mean it look it looks like
he don't even sleep like he just stays
up all night and fights you know this
guy is you want to talk about somebody
that seem like they just absolute a
gentleman of the sport and I don't mean
gentle in the word gentle I mean a
leatherneck but I'm talking about a the
a concierge of the sport you know this
man you know he just I mean it's just
he's a he's a he's a technician you can
tell that he loves it is in him you know
and it's not in him like a fever some of
these guys this fight seems like it's in
him like a fever but mr. Eddie Alvarez
it seen
like it is in him at a level that is
that is technical as well and and mr.
Dustin Poirier he's out of Louisiana you
know he's out of the Louisiana that
party a so he's seen you know that party
a so it seemed like by the time you even
said his name it seemed like you just
like you've already French kissed the
air just saying his name you know mr.
Poirot a you know it seemed like you and
the air might already you know be ready
for a second date but here you go man
these two bad boys are going at it and I
tuned into this one man I don't tune in
a lot of the fights but I love watching
Louisiana fighters and Poirier out of
Lafayette but based out of Coconut Creek
down there in Florida and I'm a big fan
of both him and mr. Cormier so this
fight starts out and they just testing
each other out but they're fast about it
you know sometime you watch these UFC
fights and he's you know they barely
touch each other the first round they're
just looking at each other you know some
of it seemed like it's like kind of
dirty ballet that you might pay extra
for and watch in like the basement of
like a New York kind of like you know
some like shady place in New York or in
like downtown Toledo or something but
these two boy men they got in the ring
and immediately they was you know they
was starting to figure it out it was
almost like they were just they picked
up right from where their last fight
ended you know and at a certain point
you see kind of like Alvarez kind of
does this spin move and then Poirier
kind of jumps into him but doesn't do
anything and that part to me kind of
reminded me of you ever like started
playing on xbox and you didn't know how
to use the control and you're just
trying the buttons out that's what it
kind of seemed like to me like you see
like Alvarez like okay this is what uh
this is what the right push right does
and then um you you see pori is like
okay this one jumps but I oh I forgot to
press kick so like you kind of see I'm
like kind of testing out all their moves
you know and you see Poirier he's got
them see got snakes in his arms do not
bet if you looked around his
neighborhood over there in Coconut Creek
and you checked the armed you know pet
store missing pets I bet they got a
couple of cotton
it's missing I bet they got a couple of
dangerous cottonmouth snakes that are
missing and I bet if you look inside of
his arms you'll find a couple of snakes
because that man he got that arm comes
out and then [ __ ] bite you at the end
that thing comes out hard and straight
bro you know and it might be cottonmouth
but it's like about 9,000 percent cotton
you know he got that [ __ ] hard
cottonmouth to walk and they're mixing
it up and no homo here but Eddie's got
that beautiful body I mean Eddie Alvarez
if you look at Eddie I mean he looked
like you know I don't think he's barely
on that he may have one tattoo doesn't
look like he has any but he's got that I
mean he could be like a model and like
Miami model hats model cigars you know
like he seemed like that guy but Donna
you know he's got that you know he's got
that couple where I on him you know he's
got that Miami handsome you know and
these boys they're going at it they go
at it hard it's not like it means you
know like I said some of these fights
start out solved but these boys go at it
immediately you know like a couple of
ham hunters you know when they heard
that the winner of this fight gets that
best cut of ham you know the and that
that's that they swing it for good ham
you know I'm saying these ain't no these
ain't no butterball you know these ain't
no butterball bad boys these some honey
baked hunters you know what I'm saying
they're going for those good hits
because they want that that you know I'm
saying they're going for that top prize
now they keep cruising on and using
different tactics here and you see Eddie
Alvarez there's this moment where he you
kind of he kind of goes for for Dustin's
waist and it's like he tries to I don't
fear seen like a kidnapper at a mall
when he tried to rush somebody and push
him into a van but he goes for that you
know that kidnapper into the van kind of
thrust waste move and then he backs out
of it when Dustin kind of slips out and
and then Dustin kind of counters a
little later you see him with this you
know he kind of do this you know it's
like the stanky leg but it's with his
arm it's kind of like you ever seen that
move where somebody's kind of looking
for a light switch in the dark that's
kind of that you know it's kind of like
if you've been looking for a light
switch in the dark it's like you don't
know where it is but he's still out
there you know you got that it's kind of
like a metal detector when you put in
that arm out in front like that while
metal detector and it's ineffective but
he's also he's just kind of you know
both these guys
kind of feeling each other out at this
point and at the end of the first round
it's this thing is the crowd is into it
there's a fervor and uh and Alvarez is
throwing them cat strikes you know you
ever spent time around a cat and a cat
sometime you think oh we're friends this
cat likes me you kind of pet that cat or
suddenly you think it's just resting and
suddenly that cattle just [ __ ] you up
like that and that's like Alvarez
you know Alvarez you think he's being
complacent or something you you you let
him for a second think that he's getting
you know getting tired or anything and
then BAM bruh that [ __ ] cat strike
you know so they rasslin you know and
they wrastlin wildly and then Poirier
gets him in that headlock Poirier
suddenly you know they were there round
and about and they're touching each
other's bodies really aggressively and
next you know Poirier he's got him in
that hard scarf Cory's got him in that
hard [ __ ] scarf boy and that things
about thirty thousand percent cotton
bruh and in sixteen thousand percent
wool and that's the hardest scarf you
ever could even be in and you don't
think that um that Alvarez is gonna get
out of it but Alvarez kind of right you
know he keeps his airway open enough and
I don't know enough technical
technically what did a lot of these
things are called and I'm have to ask
Eddie Bravo whenever I talked to him a
little bit more about this fight so he
can take me through it and look I'm not
I'm not trying to make fun of these at
either one of these men would could whip
my ass probably in their sleep yeah
maybe even in a coma both these men
could whip my ass but you see that how
that Poirier hasn't been that hard scarf
and this where Alvarez flips the script
you know he slips out of that hard scarf
and next thing you know he's got poor a
up against the cage and he's really and
this for me this this got a little bit
you know a little crotchy you know it
seemed like and look I know you use
every element it seems like these men
are warriors
these men are Roman warriors and but it
seemed like a little bit of like the me2
movement kind of it seemed like you know
Poirier was kind of like it almost
seemed like you know maybe a cop should
show up and just you know make sure this
ain't a damn domestic dispute because it
was just
this thing seemed a little crotch heavy
you know like suddenly my gay friends
were like oh this seems interesting when
before they hadn't been paying attention
to the television and this is the part
where they separate him cuz Eddie hits
him with that arm with that elbow
straight down the 12 to 6 they call it
you can't do that 12 to 6 that trucker
you know you remember when you were a
kid and you were driving along the
interstate and you were looking out the
window or your parents were driving
you'd look out the window you'd see a
trucker and some of them would try to
[ __ ] show you their junk or whatever
get you to you know show show your
nipples to them but the decent ones you
could go like this and it would just
pull their horn you know and that's the
only interaction you guys had and that's
what uh Eddie hits him with that [ __ ]
you know with that decent truck or horn
pull and the referee says you can't do
it you can't do that 12 to 6 you call
them you have to come in at an angle and
I didn't even know that about the fights
so I'm learning something new right
there and right after that man it really
you know honestly I couldn't even tell
exactly what was happening because the
strikes just came fast there's a knee
there's a couple of hand strikes and
Alvarez step man that guy you know he
lost Poirier took him and kept hitting
him and I thought there was a point
where I thought that the fight was over
and Alvarez still throwing punches you
know and that's when it's just so it's
amazing to see how deep and ingrained it
is into some of these men to be able to
fight and to be able to be warriors
I mean Alvarez almost reminds me of like
a character from gladiator or something
like that you know he very much has that
I think he could even have an acting
career you know he just had when you see
him you see that but I was happy that uh
you know that Poirier took it on him you
know drops a couple hits and Poirier me
he could see in his eyes his eyes go
full pupil you know what I'm saying his
eyes go full pupil in that second you're
like wow this man I mean just so zoned
in and so effortless too so effortless
you know and the UFC definitely grows on
me more and more especially as I you
know get
attempted trial like Brazilian Jujitsu
myself did I'd never be in a damn fight
man I couldn't handle myself but it
would be but watching these men in there
and seeing them get excited and seeing I
mean I feel excited even just talking
about this [ __ ] you know but the UFC
definitely grows on me because I
realized yes it is fighting yes they are
going against each other but also
there's such a there's such a
camaraderie and there's such a you know
there's such a mat there's such a level
of respect because even as as a fan you
man you just have so much respect for
these guys
just watching they're able to do that
and the fearless just to be fearless of
it you know to go out there most men
it's a huge feat they said public
speaking is most most people's biggest
fear I think it's fighting to go out
there and fight and these men go out
there and do it but it was you know much
respect to both of these men I would say
I was happy to see Poirier win you know
just see a guy from Louisiana and you
know what this fight reminded me of just
a great bar fight if it reminded me of
two of like the best bar fighters you've
ever heard of finally showed up at the
same happy hour and uh and hats off to
both those guys man hats off to both of
them thank you guys for checking out
this clip and if you want to see another
clip then you can look at this clip or
this clip either one of these so did you
pick one or he's still just watching me
do this cuz it's alarming